Tom wrote in hey what video games have
you and Pat spent the most hours playing
in your lives I don't play that many
video games I think for me it's very
clear I don't even think I've played a
new video game in a long time I play the
Mario games like the three ones from
Nintendo and Super Mario World from
Super Nintendo I've got an emulator on
my laptop whenever I travel I bust that
out and I play it I used to play I've
played those games through endless times
loved those games that would be in a one
series number two the Grand Theft Auto
series that's a game where I think from
Grand Theft Auto 3 Vice City San Andreas
for I don't know you know it right into
that range I played those all the way
through to 100% completion many many
times those are other games and then
various flight simulator games I think
that those are really the three games or
series or categories of games that I've
spent the most time playing and
otherwise I basically don't play video
games yeah I mean growing up I would
just play video games for the most part
with friends of mine George loved Super
Smash Brothers now oh yeah he won and
the racing game what does it mariokart
mariokart that's another big one yeah
the only game that I ever really got
into playing on my own was grand theft
auto 4 loved that game playing you know
with that fantastic it's a it's an
incredible game and I the things I would
have done if I had not had grand theft
auto 4 it probably be in prison right
now you would be committing all of that
real-world violence rather than video
game violence yep at that that's a good
thing that pad had that saving grace
yeah but people tell me about new games
that they're playing I don't even know
what they are I mean people talk about
they're playing I couldn't even tell you
call it with a Call of Duty
what's Call of Duty I have no idea it's
a military game military you just go
around shooting people pretty much I
mean they have a you know one that takes
place in a rock one that takes place
during World War two right you know it's
a little bit interesting but never got
into it myself check please
I'm good I just don't really have the
time to get into new game so what I do
is when I get into video game mode I
just pull out one of my old games play
it for a little bit and then I'm done
and I get back to whatever else it is
I'm doing what if the game has a good
storyline right because maybe then you
can get into it
kind of like ya reading a book or
watching a television show I guess
former producer Louis used to tell me I
don't care about gameplay anymore I've
matured now and now I play games for the
story line I don't care about the story
line I just like I just like good game
play you know that's what I'm interested
in yeah okay I really buy that Tom I
hope that my answer is not completely
disappointing to you but that is the
true answer and I think that that's
something that you can appreciate on the
bonus show today scientists say that
having older brothers increases a man's
likelihood of being gay Fiji has been
urged by the UN not to overlook people
ostracized for having albinism and
spirit boots a breastfeeding woman from
their plane yet another reason why I
think spirit is a disaster all of those
stories and more get the bonus show
david pakman.com slash membership